should i wear a mask can i see my
friends yet
how close are we to a vaccine
[Music]
hi my name is aaron brumage i am a
professor of biology
where i focus on immunology and the
control of infectious diseases
my name is dr steven morris i am
professor of epidemiology at the millman
school of public health
is it safe to fly right now so
determining whether you want to fly
or not um is really a personal choice
that needs to be made based on
a lot of different factors do you need
to how important
is it to do it if you have any of the
comorbidities that have been discussed
then
flying becomes a much more risky uh
endeavor where are you going do are you
going to be
going from some place that doesn't have
very much virus circulation to another
place that may not have much much virus
circulating around
some of the other things you need to
consider with flying is
how common are new infections in the
area that you're leaving from
so if you find yourself flying out of
new york or out of new jersey or even
massachusetts out of boston
where we are seeing a lot of community
spread
then getting on a plane with 100 or 200
other people
presents a higher risk than what it
would be if you were flying out of
alaska where they only had
a handful of cases yesterday probably
there are as many dangers going to and
from the airport
and waiting in the airport can i go to
the beach
if we maintain the precautions
especially social distancing
and if we're with other people they
should be people we know and trust
the beach being outside allows you to
physically separate from other groups to
create that needed space that buffer
that we need to get away from the
respiratory emissions that could
potentially infect you
not everyone is able or perhaps you know
willing to maintain the social
distancing we talk about so some beaches
have gotten very crowded
if so i think you should head for
another beach
try to find a more secluded spa so you
can go to the beach
but physical distancing is still
important can cover 19 live in the water
if you go to the beach and it's salt
water the chances are
that there's going to be a lot of
dilution if there is any virus
in there even if it could survive the
tides are going to sweep it away
there's going to be a lot of water to
dilute the virus
so there's probably very little risk in
that situation
this virus we haven't really studied in
detail to know that yet but if we look
at other coronaviruses
we know that infectious viral particles
can persist in both fresh and salt water
for an extended period of time
contracting it from the water would be
very hard when we're dealing with an
ocean or a large lake
because it's not just exposure to the
virus that gets you infected
it's exposure to enough virus can i see
my friends yet
any time that you possibly can have an
interaction with your friends
make sure that you're doing it outside
outside is
much safer than inside because when we
get inside the chance for
transfer of the virus just through those
tiny little droplets in the air
is dramatically increased i think
gradually we're
expanding our our circle to seeing
more friends in small groups and
limited settings just understand that
the longer that you spend with them the
closer that you
are the riskier that particular
interaction becomes
if you trust your friends and they trust
you
or if you've all been indoors staying
home and
not at risk of having been infected you
can probably see each other when is it
safe to see family again
so seeing family again follows the same
rules as
everything else we've been talking about
you've got to think about the risk
factors of your
household and the people your family
that you're visiting
there are so many grandparents i'm in
that category
who want to hug their grandchildren and
see their grandchildren again
so that's a really hard decision if
you're looking at visiting your
mother or your grandmother or
grandfather and they
have a lot of comorbidities and age
then you need to take much more
precautions
if you want to have that visit i think
that gradually as we learn more
things will open up a bit and a lot of
the risk may very well be
in how you get there and what happens in
the interim
is it risky to stay in a hotel now so
risk again comes down to personal
factors
hotel rooms are always a difficult
choice
any time that you interact with somebody
or a new place you have a chance
of becoming infected if you have to stay
in a hotel
because you're traveling look look for a
hotel that that really
uh seems to be enforcing good standards
some people become infected
and don't become sick some people become
infected and get a little bit sick
then others get really sick
and up to and including death so you've
got to look
at your risk factors about whether
staying in a hotel is actually a risky
endeavor but the risk from a hotel
really comes down to
how well that hotel is maintaining the
cleanliness of their rooms
of their lobbies of the elevators they
should be wearing masks
they should have good hand hygiene that
is to say keeping their hands clean
and probably you'll see bottles of hand
sanitizer
for you to use that's usually an
indication that they're
taking this seriously should i wear a
mask
you absolutely should be wearing a mask
when you cannot
physically distance all the time in
china
they feel very strongly that masks are
helpful
and we do know that masks can prevent
the
transmission from people who are
infected
a mask stops most of your respiratory
droplets coming out
they get caught on the inside of the
mask and just lowers
the overall viral burden that's in the
air
so yes we should wear masks but many
people have asked you know why didn't we
do this earlier
and we probably should have when will it
be safe to travel again
safety with traveling comes down again
to risk factors
i think it depends a lot on how you're
going to travel
you know travel by car for example has
always probably been pretty safe but
everything in life carries the risk
i think we're going to find that travel
in general though is very
country focused for quite a while now
so a lot of it is really taking
precautions to reduce your risk
and decide what's appropriate for you
and what's appropriate for the people
you come in contact with
what if someone sneezes on you if
someone sneezes on you ninja roll away
as quickly as you can
i think it depends on where and how they
sneeze so a sneeze can emit
thousands upon thousands of viral
particles infectious viral particles
into the air
so that's why we need the six feet space
that's why we need masks because
a mask and six feet space will stop any
of those droplets coming towards you
if we're keeping that that social
distancing hopefully
you know we would take a few steps back
if we're close
and they're sneezing on us you know i
certainly wouldn't want to be anywhere
near them
this is why we want people to wear masks
to protect
not only themselves but to protect
others when they're sneezing for example
how close are we to a covid19 vaccine
our fastest vaccine that we've
produced to date is about four and a
half years so
if we go by old standards we're looking
at four
to potentially 10 years for a vaccine
the upside with
this particular vaccine is that i have
never seen
more companies focused on a singular
effort than this one
so with that alone that gives me much
more
hope that we will get out of the bench
phase and into the phase one
two and three trials faster there's a
lot of hope obviously
for a vaccine and the answer is we don't
really know
the speed with which vaccines are being
developed
and tested is unprecedented
so i'm hopeful that we will have some
vaccine
soon even though you may not be
concerned
about your own health understand that
you actually do have a role
in this and that you may be part of the
transmission chain
that leads to it getting into a nursing
home
or getting into a school or getting it
into a place where people aren't so
fortunate
with their health and that can lead to
devastating outcomes for that group of
people
i hope we'll learn some good lessons
from this one lesson is that if we'd
acted quickly
on the global level as well as
nationally we could have probably
prevented many of the infections and
deaths we see today
[Music]
you